oh you thought I was done with this look
but guess what
I get to go raggedy here we are folks we
have arrived at Matt Smith Steven Moffat
and the eleventh hour now I have praised
the heck out of this episode before and
whenever I come to a story that I really
really like I'm both excited and nervous
nervous that I'm gonna find stuff that
I'm kind of iffy about that maybe I'd
forgotten or I glossed over or didn't
bug me but now does but I'm also excited
because it's an episode I really like
and I still really like this I will say
at this point I know I will stand by
this even though I've got more to
revisit this is the strongest first
Doctor Advent not first Doctor doctor's
first adventure this is the oven doctor
out the first it is the strongest first
outing of any doctor in the modern era
and actually if you go to my list of
best first outings of doctors it's one
of the best period but it is definitely
the best of the modern era think about
everything that this show is doing first
off we have zero recurrent characters so
we've got a whole new doctor we've got a
whole new companion we have that
companions key supporting character to
introduce we have the new showrunner so
we have a new vibe to the show that we
need to set and in addition to all of
that it would be really nice if the
story was actually worth the dang hey
you know what
it's absolutely all those things first
off Matt Smith as soon as he popped out
I was immediately intrigued by him oh my
who this is weird but but like in a good
way and I love his rapport with young
Amelia like and that's also great like
fun fact if you didn't know the actor
who plays young Amelia is any pot it not
Amy Pond
I'm on a roll today Karen Gillan's
cousin but they had never actually met
before shooting this episode so you know
he was a that's weird I've got tons of
cousins I haven't met that's what
happens when you live all the way across
the country from big chunks to your
family but in any case she's terrific
and she's got that and she's got a great
little bit of attitude she's not fazed
especially by the doctor which he points
out in a wonderful way because it
normally I'm not the biggest fan of the
world of sort of lampshade hanging of
like yeah we just acknowledge that this
is a thing that isn't normal and we just
did it or like this thing is Terry did
boom we just did it but they do kind of
hang a lampshade on the fact that she's
completely unfazed by the doctor by the
doctor pointing out no you're not scared
of anything box falls out of the sky man
falls out on the box Manny's fish
custard and look at you so that must be
a really scary crack in your wall and
Wow
I'll admit up front at the start of the
series I'm not a huge fan of the cracks
in time storyline both as a thing and
also in terms of its conclusion but as
far as the introduction of those cracks
go yeah no that's pretty much gold the
whole idea of showing it in the wall and
the doctor looking at it and going the
the crack doesn't go all the way through
where's the breeze you know when you
knock down this wall the crack would
still be there these are awesome
concepts these are wonderful ideas and
it's that borderline fairy tale feel
which not everybody likes in Doctor Who
some people some fans really want it to
lean on more hard sci-fi I like the
fairy tale vibe that Moffat would
sometimes bring I mean honestly the
weeping angels are basically a fairy
tale monster that he found a sci-fi
technobabble explanation for personally
I'm totally down for that because even
when it comes to fantasy I prefer
fairytale fantasy over epic fantasy not
that I don't like that I'm just saying
you know preferences so I like that
whole vibe and then of course there's
the fact that the doctor accidentally
leaves her for years and there's a
couple of things I love about that the
first is it establishes this doctor as
fallible he makes mistakes he doesn't
know how to pilot the TARDIS as well as
he should he screws up I like a doctor
who can screw up and is capable of not
always be doing the right thing and also
who doing the wrong thing does not
necessarily mean massive character agro
he's gone too far like no he screwed up
sometimes he screws up it happens I like
that and then I love what it does to the
dynamic of the doctor and Amy as an
adult because Amy is both you know
enamored and amazed by him but she's
also kinda over him she's kind of
already fed up with his BS in a way
which makes her actually I would say a
really interesting kind of amalgamation
of Rose Tyler and Donna and a lot of
that does come down to the performance
of Karen Gillan she brings the right
amount of basically kind of sass and
that whole I'm kind of already a ticked
off at you even though I think you're
really cool and I want to go with you
attitude does a lot to distinguish her
from Rose because on paper she could
have very easily ended up being a rose
repeat she's around the same age she is
true she is traditionally attractive she
appears to be more street smart than
book smart you know sort of a lot of
attitude to her but Amy doesn't feel
like Rose she has a distinctly different
feel and I think that element of their
dynamic is a fairly big part of why that
is I was just like seeing Amy like
interact around the town you get this
feel a bit like okay she kind of weirdly
seems to run this town like the whole
town knows about her imaginary friend
and like she uses the guys car to trap
the doctor by the tie and the guys I'm
gonna need my card she just goes yes
well do that later go have coffee and he
just lists he just doesn't like you
could just on sheer attitude you kind of
run this place don't ya and I kind of
love that and we get our introduction of
Rory and when we first introduced him I
did not realize he was going to become
what he became I thought oh okay we'll
probably see him again but I thought he
was gonna become like well a little bit
like Jackie was too rose or like a
Mickey use who never joins the tars I
thought you know he'd be someone we'd
run into but the idea of him actually
going on trips with
them I didn't think was in the cards but
his introduction here is solid it's
interesting to go back knowing how Rory
story pans out a bit more he really does
get crapped on a bit Oh and worth noting
like the doctor who he's trying to
explain to about the coma patients that
woman is a terrible doctor she's like as
a boss and just as a doctor because she
is failing to even consider what this
what her subordinate is telling her not
even like regardless of other than our
she thinks what he's saying is
ridiculous not even hearing him out or
paying him any respect whatsoever and
then she's also a crappy medical doctor
because heard what she decides to do to
the coma patient is literally stand over
though over one of them and shake him
Barney can you hear me oh my god that
woman huh
but side note that jumped out of me this
time for some reason and then like I
said that there's a lot of supporting
characters that we never see again
there's Amy's elderly neighbor there's
oh there's Jeff Jeff with his laptop I
kind of wonder whatever happened to Jeff
did like he actually get to write his
own ticket after that whole thing in him
talking the the like the super smart
people around the world into going along
with a doctor's plan which first time I
also like that the doctor basically
delegates and chunk of his plan to a guy
he doesn't know he's like look I'm busy
you need to handle this part of it I
which I like but part of me does wonder
Jeff I don't need desperately need to
know I'm not sure it would count as a
dangling plot thread necessarily for me
to like do a follow-up video um but I do
wonder a little bit but anyways what
else have we gotten this oh okay there's
a lot of little moments that really help
solidify this doctor I actually rather
like the doctor having is I missed it I
saw it I missed it wait what did I see
and it like sort of goes in and is the
unit's going all over sort of checking
it is very Sherlock X I like that it's
here but I also like that the show never
did it again basically establishing here
kind of a
inside look at how his mind works but
not making a gimmick out of it that they
do on other occasions like we
established here the speed of which he's
thinking and is replaying the
information he just took in and figuring
out from that information so now you
know how that works we don't have to
show it to you again cuz you can just
assume he does that when he needs to
cool with that
love it the atraxi are kind of
interesting to me because it's a very
basic design it's a giant eyeball in a
tech snowflake basically yeah
oddly it works or at least it does for
me and for one time sort of antagonists
um I I mean part of it might be the
voice I'm a sucker for a big deep
booming voice and I I'm not gonna say
give a total pass for that but I'm tend
to favor that so maybe that's part of
why it works for me that said I did
notice there is a lot of repetition of
the Prisoner Zero will vacate the human
residence or the human residence will be
incinerated repeat and then it does
actually repeat over and over and over
again now it's usually in the background
and I get it
but I'm gonna have an ear out for this
now Moffat seems to have a bit of a
thing for repeating dialogue over and
over and over again I noted this in my
review of silence of the librarian force
to the dead now there was when the
Vashta Nerada you know took these things
over and like the ghosting and the thing
looped but there was also like Donna
Noble has left the library Donna Noble
has been saved didn't say one just kept
repeating it over and over it looks like
Steven I don't know if you think the
repetitious thing is like somehow
unsettling or if you think we're dumb
and we're gonna forget if you don't keep
saying it but like after a while it's
annoying please don't so ya know minor
nitpicks like that I suppose as far as
major elements go if I were to single
out the weakest thing it's probably the
villain it's probably Prisoner Zero
Prisoner Zero is by no means a bad
villain but it is basically just a
functional villain there's not a lot to
this thing but the thing is for how much
other stuff this is juggling because
like I said new doctor new companion new
secondary campaign being introduced even
though he doesn't join the TARDIS yet
laying out the vibe of the thing which
is very much laid into the
the more fairytale feel and the time
jumped because Steve deceive them off it
likes to do the time of you why anything
a lot more and you don't a solid an
engaging story with the doctor being
slightly off his game not having all of
his tools and having to save the the
planet I often complain about oh and
know the planets being threatened again
but I kind of like that it's being
threatened casually not to the people of
Earth it's like it's gonna wipe them out
but like the people threatening it it's
not because they're like we're gonna
destroy Earth they're like dude get off
the planet we're just gonna burn it so
III like that but like taking to account
that it's doing all of that if something
was going to be dialed back the villain
makes sense it's kind of the same reason
that Marvel movies didn't have great
villains for kind of the first few
cycles worth the films it was because
they were going out of their way to
build really strong heroes and
supporting cast for those heroes because
those were the characters are going to
keep coming back and we needed to be
invested in if the franchise was ever
gonna work that's not to say that a good
villain if prisoners era have been a
more compelling or more interesting or
more unique villain that it wouldn't
have made it an even better story it
absolutely would but to say the villain
should be better presumes that you're
not gonna sacrifice the other stuff to
do that and the thing is I'm not sure
there's a way to make to bring too much
more to Prisoner Zero either making it
scary or making it more compelling or
whatever that doesn't involve taking
time away from the other stuff and that
would absolutely be the wrong move
because this thing is super efficient
the way it currently exists every
everything that's in there needs to be
there and really no scene goes all along
a [ __ ] well maybe the trying food like
goes on for one or two more that it show
but that's really the only thing this
thing is very carefully set up because
one of the really key things about good
efficient storytelling efficient is not
the same as at breakneck speed and
always going super fast truly efficient
means you also know when to slow down
and you have trimmed the fat off your
other parts that you have the time to
slow down where it matters in scenes
like little Emilia bonding with the
doctor or the doctor convincing grown
Amy why
she should listen to him you slowed down
during those scenes because there's no
superfluous nonsense in the stuff where
it doesn't need to be so you have the
space to breathe in those moments it is
proper efficient storytelling and I love
it I'm not sure what else there is for
me to say like like I said couple little
nitpicky things eh I'm not even gonna
say I wish there was a bit more to the
to the villain but like I'll cop to the
villain being the the least yeah element
of the thing but he still works Prisoner
Zero absolutely still functions and does
perfectly well for what needs to be
there um oh I guess one other nitpicky
thing and this actually even bothered me
early on I don't think they do the
corner of your eye bit quite right
because I really think they should have
had in standard shots have whatever is
out of the corner of your eye that
you're supposed to catch not be visible
so like when Amy is counting the doors
and there's a door she doesn't notice
until the doctor tells her to cash it
out of the corner of her eye that door
shouldn't have been there in in other
shots it shouldn't have been there until
she took the turn and the camera takes
her view and it catches it and there it
is and now there's a door
same with Prisoner Zero being in that
room with her he we should not have been
able to see it just behind her and then
she does the turn no should have been
nothing in there maybe we hear something
and it's not until she does the turn
that we see it so I feel like visually
they didn't quite pull off my concept of
you've got to catch it out of the corner
right which is a shame because I do
really like that idea but again like
these things that are mentioning their
little tiny nitpicks and in though in
the face of this man in a bowtie walking
through the image of Tennant in going
hello I'm the doctor
that
nothing else matters like every almost
everything else is still really good but
even if it wasn't that moment is gold
absolute solid gold I remember saying
out loud first time I ever saw this when
it aired yes you are and yes he is I
also like that music I like that too and
I like the I am the doctor track I
mentioned that before when I've talked
about this music and some people might
be like wait haven't you complained
before about like the doctor treading on
his reputation I have but there's a
crucial difference here versus some of
the times that happen later I'm actually
gonna be devoting a whole video on what
does or doesn't work for me about the
doctors reputation and how big or small
I feel it should be because I've brushed
past it before I really want to dive
into it specifically as its own thing
but what I'll say here is to me the
crucial bit of difference the crucial
little twist in it is that the atraxi
don't already know who he is they don't
know him by name they don't know him by
reputation
they only realize that he is dangerous
after they look into who has stopped any
other invaders coming here so like the
Vashta Nerada before them they had to
look him up so it's basically this is
gonna be really weird comparison but the
heck would they go with it it's the
difference between you I'm just gonna
say you I'm presuming you wouldn't
actually do this because you're a nice
person you don't pick fights but here we
go so it's the difference between you
getting in somebody's face at a bar and
then being warned off by other people
saying hey look that person is like an
MMA fighter with multiple championships
and then you hear that you're like oh
okay and then you back off it's the
difference between that and walking into
a bar seeing this person and immediately
knowing their name and all that stuff
about them already and I do think that
is actually a fairly significant
difference in terms of you're scared of
them because you find out what they're
capable of and you're scared of them
because you already knew who they were
that is the difference in scale of
reputation so what is done here I'm
actually totally cool with what gets
done later on
I'm not as cool with as I said I'll
probably do a whole video on that a
little bit later next month next month
yeah I'm trying to keeping track of
where I am in terms of where I'm
recording versus when it's coming out
with whatever 11th hour you see know
what you think about it whatever your
thoughts were drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it a bunch of
stuff to do like subscribe it is greatly
appreciated both of those are actually a
really big help there's also the patreon
if you want to help me grow this channel
and support me and maybe one day even
like have this be what I do and who
knows what I'd be able to accomplish if
that's the case but huh dreams in any
case there's links to that links to a
book I wrote socials p.o box address etc
etc etc all down to the in the
description below click on stuff or
don't if you don't want to that's ok
because at the end of the day you're the
council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]